as to macroeconomic conditionality
the spanish government does not believe
that we should use this
in order to sanction those countries
that cannot comply with economic
conditionality by taking away
structural funds
i mean this is something that will
impact all member states
this is not about the invasion of the
national sovereignty or taxation
sovereignty of over member states the
decision on own resources has to be
ratified by the national parliament so
this is absolutely
the domain of fiscal responsibility of
the member states this is not to grow
the budget in fact our budget in
relation to gni is falling down in
relation of what is now and what was in
the 90s so we are taking into account
the rigors and restraints of the present
present-day europe i believe it is our
responsibility to
translate the message from the european
council into the concrete steps and i
think that uh i have no doubts that the
the mff discussion this is a blueprint
for growth in europe until 20
until 2020.
we believe that the quality of spending
is important however better spending
should not mean
less spending
good results over negotiations would be
to reach an agreement where everyone is
equally unhappy
our
overarching challenge is to combine
budgetary consolidation with a growth
oriented reform and we need to do both
we need to find
the 100 billion savings in the
commission proposal we must stabilize
the budget
and i would refer
to the letter signed by several heads of
state already in the end of 2010
and we need to modernize our
expenditures and to spend it better
which means
we prioritize towards future challenges
competitiveness research and innovation
and internal security
but we have come a long way since
commission tabled its proposal since
last summer and it is of utmost
importance that we keep the pace up and
have an agreement by the end of this
year
on macroeconomic conditionality we
support measures to improve economic
governance but we don't support using
structure and cohesion funds as a
backdoor mechanism to circumvent our
agreements in that area
structure and cohesion funds need to be
used to the purpose they were intended
as economic convergence mechanisms
and i fear that using them as an
economic governance enforcement tool
undermines their purpose politicizes
their use and it doesn't respect member
state competence that was set out by the
van rompuy task force to which all 27 of
us agreed or protocol 15 of the treaties
due to the promotion of internal
development cohesion policy is an
economic growth facilitating policy
latvia's main concern is a problem of
capping in countries with a significant
gdp drop the tax proposal of the
presidency
goes in the right direction and we are
ready to continue its further
development
we think that the mff
should
economic growth thereby to create jobs
spending better spending well
and in the interest of citizens
then cohesion policy implementation
that policy is central in the union's
growth strategy and we need to apply it
in the best possible way thus
co-financing rates need to be set at the
current
levels at national level respecting the
restrictions that member states have to
contend with at the moment
also know that limiting expenditure is
the best guarantee of ensuring that
national transfers to the eu budget will
be kept under control
so all of this of course must be seen
subject to the condition that we reach
overall agreement we are nonetheless
prepared to continue making the biggest
net contribution but burden sharing must
be fairer and we need to therefore have
some sort of compensation
i think the discussions over the next
couple of months will allow us to
actually put things into practice we
can't just keep talking about
growth
forever in the day without actually
daring to
do something with the budget and i think
we do need to talk much more about our
investment policy in the eu we need to
have the means to achieve eu's important
goals
of growth cohesion and development
we cannot set ambitious goals as regards
the europe's 2020 strategy without
providing the necessary financial
instruments for the implementation
europe has to remain competitive and
coherent with its own agenda
let me start by saying that the
commission proposal can offer some
valuable contribution to sustainable
growth and employment
however given the need for
fiscal consolidation
we must be guided by the principle of
spending better rather than spending
more
on the cutting back on own resources
that will not help
again member states it will just
increase the gap between the different
regions which does not comply with the
objectives of the lisbon agenda
the european council
met last week to examine how we can turn
what we say about growth in europe into
concrete actions
and it's important important question uh
and the new mff has to be seen as a part
of the answer
that means providing ourselves with the
budget we need
one that is no bigger than is strictly
required
and but one that is consistent with our
goals and our ambitions
as regards the proposal
of macroeconomic conditionalities even
shall we understand the reasoning behind
this proposal
we cannot support these conditions in
their current form they're never ready
to discuss this issue further in a
constructive manner in order to make the
condition that is fair and limited in
the scope
we have to be ambitious in
the budget
so that we can attain the objectives
that we need in terms of growth and to
make sure that europe is put back on a
growth track and to make sure that we
are not faced with an everlasting
recession but at the same time we have
to make sure that the budget
contributions
allocated to the commission to attain
those objectives is reasonable
now we are
perfectly willing to examine the
proposals put forward by the commission
however we feel that this debate
should go beyond the terms of the
current debate we need to enter into
political commitments but look at
alternative proposals over the longer
term
we firmly believe
the next mff should be focused on
meeting eu 2020 strategy goals boosting
growth and employment
the main priorities of slovenia remain
unchanged cohesion policy and rural
development
i think it is important that we focus on
a better spending in order to improve
competitiveness and growth in the union
in these times of austerity this has to
be
achieved with the disciplined
mff i believe that having an honest
debate on the quality of spending in
connection with the need for solidarity
and convergence growth and jobs and
examining both the revenue and the
expenditure expenditure side in parallel
are important to reach an overall
balanced agreement
we also must focus on measures
contributing to growth which provides
european added value and we cannot
afford to do otherwise in this tough
financial economic situation
we need to stimulate growth and
employment and it is justified with
well-defined increases compared to
present period in research and
development and innovations in strategic
cross-border infrastructures in
environment and climate and as well as
security and external policy
we can consider it as a key that
cohesion policy should be better linked
to the eu 2020 goals and it should
support structural reforms therefore we
do share the aim that we need to spend
better however i also agree with those
who are saying that better spending does
not mean spending less and better
spending is a principle which applies to
all expenditure headings
malta considers the overall proposed
budget equation policy as the minimum
possible to address the present economic
social and territorial
it is important that cohesion policy is
focused on the less developed regions
and the regions exiting the convergence
objective
caucasian policies should focus on the
less developed regions and member states
in order to achieve economic social and
territorial cohesion
this means that
these countries will need more financing
in order to close the gap
while appreciating the need for the more
equitable distribution of direct
payments
we have to stress the fact that at the
beginning of the next mff croatia will
only start a long phasing in period that
will last well beyond 2020.
cuts on croatia's allocations at this
point would bring us further from fair
distribution in the first pillar
many of you insisted on the need to
enhance growth job and investment
through this mff
many also agreed that this mff should
ensure a better quality of expenditure
a number of you consider that these
principles should apply in all policy
areas
today we discussed for the first time
the revenue side we know that this part
will be an integral and very important
component of the final agreement